[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en francés 24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares vamos a kenia donde
las elecciones generales tienen como
telón de fondo el encarecimiento del
costo de vida y una creciente apatía por
la política analizamos la situación
terror en madagascar donde 32 personas
entre ellas 15 menores de edad fueron
quemadas vivas la policía sospecha de
los daã lo nombre dado a los cuatreros
en ese país un equipo de france 24 en
francés estuvo en el lugar de los hechos
y como consecuencia frente a la subida
de los precios en nigeria los habitantes
se ven obligados a comprar todos sus
productos de primera necesidad en
pequeñas cantidades y en minúsculas
bolsas de plástico siendo esto poco
económico e incrementando el daño
ecológico
empezamos en kenia donde se viven unas
importantes elecciones presidenciales
legislativas y locales en un contexto de
fuerte descontento político y de
altísimo incremento del costo de la vida
antes de analizar lo que está en juego
en estas elecciones veamos aquí algunos
datos económicos y demográficos del país
la población keniana de más de 50
millones de personas es mayoritariamente
joven y cristiana la capital del país es
nairobi y los idiomas que se hablan son
principalmente el inglés y el swahili
kenia es una de las economías más
dinámicas de áfrica oriental y tiene un
perfil atípico en el continente cuenta
con relativamente pocos recursos
naturales pero con una economía fuerte
basada sobre todo en el sector de
servicios y en el agrícola principal
fuente de exportaciones sin embargo las
desigualdades son evidentes en el país
donde los campos de golf de lujo limitan
con los barrios pobres y donde el
salario mínimo mensual es de 126 dólares
según la ong oxfam internacional la
riqueza de los dos kenianos más ricos es
mayor que los ingresos combinados del 30
por ciento de la población es decir
16,5 millones de personas
tras un descenso del 0 3% del pib a raíz
de la pandemia en 2020 la economía de
kenia comenzó a recuperarse en el año
2021 pero este 2022 en parte debido a la
guerra en ucrania los precios de los
combustibles y los alimentos se han
disparado
mientras el país cambia de presidente
averiguamos cuáles son las expectativas
de los ciudadanos esto es lo que nos
dijo desde nairobi david soler analista
político y director del sitio web áfrica
mundi
bueno lo primero que esperan los
kenianos sin lugar a duda es que cambie
ya la situación actual y la inflación
bueno no solo es por la guerra de
ucrania que evidentemente tenía un
factor súper importante porque quería
importa el 80 más del 80 por ciento del
trigo del 3 rusia y ucrania como muchos
países del mundo pero eso ha hecho que
suba el precio de productos básicos y la
inflación esté a un pico de 5 años
entonces la gente al final te viene a
decir que no tienen con qué comer hay
mucha gente que ha pasado de dos
comillas a una comida al día que por
ejemplo el chapati que es el típico pan
aquí tipo de pita por decirlo así se ha
reducido a la mitad su tamaño para poder
mantener un precio de 10 y celine es
la gente lo que quiere es tener una
mejor situación económica y en los
últimos años tenía aunque han mejorado
mucho macro económicamente el país ha
crecido la economía crece etcétera los
ciudadanos de a pie no lo notan el otro
día hablando por un economista de la
universidad de aerobic decía que eso es
lo que le dicen sus
estudiantes y ciudadanos hasta el final
ven que hay muchos proyectos grandes
infraestructuras
que el país por decirlo así
en las noticias parece que vaya
avanzando pero ellos no ven el dinero
entonces necesitan alguna manera que la
economía mejore para ellos y sobre todo
para los jóvenes que son los que más la
sufren en el desempleo y esta subida de
los precios las elecciones en kenia no
sólo tienen importancia nacional como ya
se mencionó el país es el motor
económico de áfrica oriental y cuenta
con peso político en la región y el
resto del continente
bueno quería es en el este de áfrica es
el país más estable que tiene digamos
liderazgo geopolítico del este de áfrica
pongamos que a su lado hay países o bien
con conflictos muy en realizadores desde
hace muchos años como puede ser sudán
del sur aunque linda al norte más
recientes como por ejemplo etiopía que
aunque sí que tenga un peso geopolítico
importante por ser sede de la unión
africana no consigue ese liderazgo y que
ni así quería es un país relativamente
inestable que la economía no para de
crecer ya nosotros la mayor economía en
el este de áfrica sino la sexta en todo
en toda áfrica todo el continente
africano y además durante los últimos
mandatos de juro keniata se ha sabido
posicionar como ese rol diplomático
clave en el continente por ejemplo para
los procesos de paz en sudán del sur han
acogido a los líderes en nairobi y
también lo ha hecho más recientemente
entre los conflictos con roban de
república democrática del congo
acogiendo a líderes para poder hacerlo
un acuerdo de paz similar también en
etiopía donde ha tenido buena relación
con el primer ministro había semen
entonces querían digamos que es un un
país vital donde la estabilidad
clave ayuda mucho porque es una de las
principales rutas de comercio hacia el
interior del centro de áfrica y gana
otros países del cuerno de áfrica y
estas elecciones son vitales para ver
cómo va el país y especialmente el que
no haya violencia es también súper
importante para otros países porque si
tenía acá en la inestabilidad ya
prácticamente habría muy pocos los
países con una estabilidad continuada y
un liderazgo aparte de todo eso también
hay que decir que querían es uno de los
países pocos países más estables es
digamos en las alianzas que tiene con
occidente no aparte de otros países que
se han tenido muy buenas relaciones
más con rusia por ejemplo tenía
defendido tanto en la onu con su con su
enviado especial como económicamente
acuerdos con occidente muy potentes
incluso con el presidente donald trump
llegaron a
acordar un acuerdo bilateral de comercio
y para haciendo también es muy
importante quería entonces están seguros
de que la propiedad embajada
estadounidense tiene un ojo muy
importante aquí
seguimos hablando de elecciones pero
vamos al otro extremo del continente en
senegal el oficialismo ha perdido la
mayoría absoluta en la asamblea nacional
según los resultados provisionales de
las elecciones legislativas del 31 de
julio es la primera vez desde la
independencia del país en 1960 que el
partido en el poder ejecutivo pierde la
mayoría en el órgano legislativo y que
por lo tanto tendrá que apoyarse en
otras fuerzas del parlamento para
aprobar sus propuestas la bancada del
presidente macky sall pasa de 125
diputados a 82 del total de 165 con los
que cuenta la asamblea mientras que la
oposición obtuvo 80 escaños según
expertos y observadores estos resultados
podrían convencer al presidente de
renunciar al proyecto de reforma legal
que le permitiría volver a presentarse
en las elecciones presidenciales de 2024
cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a
madagascar donde 32 personas entre ellas
15 menores de edad fueron quemadas vivas
en el interior de sus viviendas la
masacre tuvo lugar en ancash v en la
provincia de antananarivo la capital la
policia malgache ha detenido a cinco
hombres acusados de haber cometido el
crimen mientras avanzan las
investigaciones las autoridades
sospechan que los da a los ladrones de
ganado estén detrás del hecho
cenizas cuerpos incinerados y ropa
calcinada es todo lo que queda de esa
trágica noche el 29 de julio mientras el
sol salía 32 personas se refugiaron en
esta casa en un intento fallido de
escapar de los déjalo nombre que reciben
las bandas que aterrorizan a madagascar
los atacantes incendiaron la casa 29
personas fueron quemadas vivas entre
ellas 15 niños un tercio de los
habitantes de la aldea ahora abandonada
murieron albert vio lo que pasó
y los deja lo quemaron esa casa de allí
y yo estaba escondido en esa casa
y en cuanto se quemó la vivienda la
rodearon para que los que estaban
adentro no pudieran escapar por la
ventana
los déjalo también vinieron por este
hombre un padre de 27 años que consiguió
escapar saltando por la ventana su mujer
y sus cuatro hijos murieron unos meses
antes su padre fue asesinado a tiros
cuando se dirigía al mercado así es
según él como los deja lo reafirman su
autoridad en los pueblos que creen les
son hostiles sochi está tan en moscú la
causa es que mi padre era cercano a los
dirigentes y cuando había personas de
alto rango cercanas al poder que venían
a nuestra aldea eran acogidas por mi
padre y los laja lo consideraban que
esto era una denuncia 7 los agota
el terror en las aldeas por parte de los
delincuentes violentos se está
convirtiendo en una realidad cotidiana
en muchas zonas rurales de madagascar
incluso la policía está a punto de
rendirse cuando josué intentó llamarlos
fue ignorado ahora cuenta con amuletos
como protección cuando la policía hace
redadas allí no logran nunca atrapar a
los bajo los que siempre se escapan y la
policía además no me creyó como si yo me
hiciera entonces prefería recurrir a los
que en aldeas en magia
el presidente prometió justicia pero el
ejército de la isla no ha conseguido
hasta ahora poner fin a las masacres los
dejalos son cada vez más poderosos
financiados con ganado robado y
protegidos por autoridades corruptas una
problemática que de no abordar se podría
empujar al país hacia una guerra civil
y pasamos ahora a nigeria sin más
alternativas ante el aumento de los
precios
muchos ciudadanos compran ahora todos
sus productos de primera necesidad en
cantidades minúsculas y en pequeñas
bolsas de plástico para muchos se trata
de una mala estrategia económica en
términos de gasto que también afecta al
medio ambiente enviamos
5 gramos de pasta de dientes o 10
centilitros de aceite de cocina
asfixiados por el coste de la vida los
nigerianos compran ahora todas sus
necesidades básicas en pequeñas
cantidades
empaquetadas en minúsculas bolsas de
plástico para consumirlas en un día café
o leche en polvo para una sola taza unos
gramos de cereales para el desayuno todo
se vende ahora en bolsitas
la situación es muy difícil antes si
alguien quería comprar aceite de
cacahuate no hay problema pero ahora no
hay dinero y las cosas son muy caras
ansiedad de despensa las marcas detrás
de esta idea la ven como una innovación
que permite el acceso al consumo a todos
los nigerianos la mayoría de los cuales
sobreviven día a día pero para otros es
una aberración económica y ecológica
impacto o vista de konami min el impacto
del uso de bolsas en la economía
significa que tenemos más plásticos de
un solo uso que se vierte en el medio
ambiente a un ritmo muy muy alarmante lo
que está causando mucha preocupación
para el océano las personas y el planeta
han planet la mayor economía de áfrica
se ha visto muy afectada por la en el 19
que ha hecho subir los precios en cerca
del 20 en junio de 2022 frente al mismo
mes del año pasado especialmente los de
los alimentos empujando a otros millones
de nigerianos a la pobreza ahora el país
sufre las consecuencias de la guerra de
ucrania y de una política económica muy
criticada las bolsas pequeñas
aparecieron por primera vez en el
mercado nigeriano a principios de la
década de 2010 con marcas que ofrecían a
los consumidores cantidades reducidas
para animarles a probar nuevos productos
pero en 2016 cuando el país cayó en
recesión por primera vez tras la caída
de los precios del petróleo los usuarios
comenzaron a utilizar este formato en
masa desde entonces la situación
económica no ha mejorado mucho por lo
que la demanda de pequeños envases de
plástico ha seguido disparándose así
termina la edición de esta semana
gracias a rosa pérez por su ayuda y
gracias a ustedes por su sintonía la
actualidad internacional continúa en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]